we will continue let's go next to our
caller from the 7 to 4 area code caller
in 724 what's your name where are you
calling from and what's your question
today
hi my name is Roger calling from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania right and I was
told by a few of my friends that they
think that as part of James commis
testimony they think some of the stuff
he had said about tents knowing about
some things and they've blocked pets
from becoming president if Trump is to
get impeached
yeah well they'd be a very relevant
question and we talked about this
earlier in the week when I reported that
Mike Pence himself has has retained a
personal lawyer in the Trump Russia
stuff that this is a business or a
fundamental question Pat when we think
about the impeachment or resignation of
Donald Trump does Mike Pence become
president and then what happens and how
implicated is Mike Pence in whatever is
the full extent of the Trump Russia
scandal I wouldn't be shocked whether
it's true or not to see pence turn his
back on Trump if it gets really ugly and
say listen they brought me in when all
this Russian stuff was going on I didn't
participate in any of it they wouldn't
keep me in the loop I'm clean here it's
already a little hard to believe only
because it appears that pence was aware
of the distortions that Michael Flynn
was involved in maybe I mean we don't
even have allegations directly against
Michael Mike Patton we don't really
don't you know you have to start with
that position first we have that with
Mike Flynn we have that with Paul
Manafort not so much for Mike Pence yeah
no but I think your question Roger is
spot-on which is we don't know the
answer to that and that is going to
become if this progresses that's going
to become a bigger and bigger issue okay
yeah all right thank you so much for the
call really really appreciated a very
important topic and one that I think we
will have to at some point follow again
very very closely